a ukrainian tank fires down a street
almost completely destroyed
soldiers take cover underground as what
sounds like an artillery shell explodes
close by these men are defending the
last areas of severe donetsk still under
their control from the slow russian
advance
ammunition and supplies are ferried
across the river from neighbouring
lesichansk the four bridges that
connected them are destroyed
fighting has been intense here for weeks
because these are the only two cities in
the lugansk region that russia hasn't
taken ukrainian reinforcements head to
the front line many of these men had
never held a gun before the war started
and they come from all walks of life the
government says hundreds of ukrainian
soldiers are being killed every day
there is little verifiable information
on how many russians are dying
the situation on the front line hasn't
significantly changed thanks to tactical
maneuvers the ukrainian army is
strengthening its defense of the luhansk
region that is really the toughest spot
the occupiers are pressing strongly and
also in the dynastic direction in the
kharkiv region
this video was supplied to the reuters
news agency by russian forces it
reportedly shows pro-russia separatists
advancing on ukrainian positions near
civil dynetsk the fighter shows western
supplied military hardware including an
anti-tank system night vision equipment
and rifles that he says were abandoned
by retreating ukrainian forces he says
the blurred out bodies are ukrainian
soldiers
we will continue to make inroads into
their lines to fully surround them i
think if they're not idiots they will
surrender if they don't want to
surrender they will die
the ukrainian army says russian forces
have cut supply routes from two villages
south of lusichansk and several donetsk
the head of lugansk military
administration confirms that claim
and says that russian forces have taken
control of another three villages in the
same area there are also reports that
russian forces are advancing close to
the azot chemical plant inside several
donetsk
where it's understood that hundreds of
civilians including women and children
are sheltering inside charles stratford
al jazeera kiev